[Musica]
un'idea di per sé non produce la loro
economico e non produce neanche
innovazione un'idea forse è meglio dire
un'intuizione certamente un elemento
chiara da teheran impresa innovativa ma
il vero lavoro dell'innovatore è
soprattutto quello di realizzare una
nuova soluzione anche perché
realizzandola spesso ci si rende conto
che forse mai ma poi in fondo così
chiara questa idea magari neanche così
brillante innovatori che si innamora di
una sua idea quindi in realtà non è un
bravo innovatore ed è anche un bravo
imprenditore che però imprenditore sa
che il suo compito è quello di
confezionare un offerta prima non
esisteva portava sul mercato e poi
verificare se sia in grado di rivelare o
quantomeno di stimolare il segnale di
una nuova domanda a questo punto poi con
una domanda il mercato si è manifestata
anche altri imprenditori e poi posso non
accogliere le opportunità
a quel punto lino maggioranza più io mi
occupo di tecnologie digitali e quella
della tecnologia digitale è proprio
un'attitudine innata a rinnovare il
motivo è che abilita trasformazioni
radicali e quindi si può rimettere in
discussione tutto quanto sono almeno due
le grandi capacità che la scienza
l'informazioni offre l'innovatore una è
l'elaborazione dell'informazione che li
la capacità di estrarre nuovo valore da
ciò che già esiste e la seconda la
distribuzione dell'informazione che
promette allineare gli interessi tutti
gli attori della filiera e quindi
svelare anche con l'opportunità di
efficienza associazione la strategica e
roche che molti confondono digitale con
il computer gli smartphone eccetera
tra questi sono dispositivi che funga
ormai interfaccia per interagire per
fruire dell'informazione ma in realtà
l'influenza del digitale per batte
largamente il mondo fisico oggi
prendiamo il mondo di trasporto delle
merci
che forse dominio più fisico qui
possiamo pensare lo si sposta nei pacchi
tra l'altro esiste più o meno da quando
esiste la ruota e quindi vive anche di
practice radicata e difficile da
scalzare quindi un terreno perfetto per
analizzare e potenzialità ma anche le
sfide dell'accelerazione digitale
facciamo un esempio concreto tutti voi
avrete fatto un acquisto su internet
immaginate però per un momento di essen
ogni consumatore ma il corriere c'è
l'azienda che sta in mezzo dal venditore
e il consumatore
diciamo chiedere imprenditore di questa
azienda bene dobbiamo ritirare un
prodotto da un venditore e consegnarlo a
un consumatore che l'ha appena
acquistata dobbiamo essere veloci se no
il consumatore che vincevano acquistare
da un altro venditore oppure addirittura
non compra a niente
questo causerebbe un disastro per il
nostro cliente che il venditore
ovviamente sarà affidabili se non
riusciamo a rispettare le promesse il
consumatore ci penalizza pubblicamente
sui social e ci rovina la reputazione ma
dobbiamo essere soprattutto efficienti
nel gestire i costi perché i consumatori
proprio non sembra non avere alcuna
voglia di pagare un costo della
spedizione
ora tutto questo ovviamente si è
complicato in alta e anche molto più di
così
ma quando si indispensabile bloccare
l'uso di tecnologie sofisticate in fondo
nel progresso sempre avuto un segreto
molto semplice per risolvere problemi
anche complessi e cioè con l'economia
capitalistica imprenditori indipendenti
si organizzano spontaneamente in filiere
ciascuno si occupa del suo piccolo sotto
problema e guarda la massimizzazione del
suo profitto creando così una catena ma
supply chain in cui ciascuno nello pensa
per sé tanto e quando premiamo il
pulsante acquista sul sito di e commerce
in alta stiamo mettendo in moto più di
una dozzina di ragioni sociali
indipendenti autonomi
se trovate dei servizi logistici che
gestisce il magazine e partenza
cooperativa movimentazione il camionista
da ridire l'aver c'e poi finali
giustamente trazioni distribuzioni
funziona comunque però ad ogni
interfaccia ad ogni nuovo anello di
questa lunga catena
in realtà si perdono delle opportunità
si ammettono anche degli errori come
abbiamo per esempio l'ultimo miglio non
avete gli autisti non pagati in fila
consenta così si garantisce che ce la
mettano tutta per massimizzare il numero
dei pacchi che consegnano ogni giorno
non riusciranno poi a consegnare il
nostro
e come fanno sapere che noi magari siamo
già usciti per andare a prendere il
bambino a scuola
guardiamo anche al costo tra l'altro
mettiamo dove visitare dieci indirizzi
abbiamo più di tre milioni e mezzo di
possibili sequenze alternative per
visitarli tutti e tra queste si nasconde
quella di economica corriere normalmente
fa circa 80 consegna il giorno e quindi
di sequenze possibili e di gran lunga
superiore al numero di armi
dell'universo un fan autista capire qual
è la sequenza più economica è qui che i
calcolatori possano mostrare il loro
straordinario valore di elaborazione
questo e facendo dell'umano lo prendo il
dato cartografico simulano un enorme
numero di soluzioni possibili
considerando esigenze orarie vincoli
logistici i ritmi sono molti altri che
calcola poi percorsi di efficienti per
tutta la flotta
questo è il potere algoritmico del
processing stesso tempo però il digitale
permette anche l'integrazione dei
processi lungo tutti gli anelli questa
filiera e quindi fa cercare informazioni
così ci guadagnano tutti intanto a voi
che ora potete dire al corriere a che
ora intende the line disponibili a
ricevere i vostri acquisti a casa c'è
chi finalmente sapete anche ora arriva
il corriere in cui sapete che la legge
di ma ti impone che se portate fuori il
cane il consiglio che arriva in
quell'esatto momento il venditore così
c'è un vantaggio competitivo nuovo
autista che riceve aggiornamenti in
tempo reale
e poi il pianeta anche perché a questo
punto possiamo proporre lo stesso orario
anche i vostri vicini se loro sta bene
accorpiamo nel consegnare diciamo
l'impatto ambientale tutto questo
abilitato solo fatto di essere tutti
sullo stesso sistema digitale che quindi
in grado di distribuire l'informazione
in modo puntuale
ecco dunque come possiamo aiutare a
trasformare un dominio fisico per creare
nuovo valore grazie alla sola
introduzione dimostrato intelligenza
tecnologica su infrastruttura fisica di
magazzini di veicoli di autisti già
esistenti ed ecco come un imprenditore a
digitare come un impatto sull'economia
reale verità però è che per permettere
questi vantaggi in realtà tutti i
rapporti nella filiera devono cambiare
anche il modo fondo cambiano i contratti
i rapporti economici che erano dati per
scontati da sempre diventa
nell'innovazione tecnologica non ci si
può limitare gli algoritmi e software
machine lerman sì devo rivisitare intera
industria identificare un valore
aggiunto per ogni singola nello favorire
l'adozione in questi processi nuovi in
tutte le fasi e rimuovere anche delle
barriere culturali e un po di ovvia
diffidenza sull'uso i nuovi strumenti
quindi io per esempio la maggior parte
del mio tempo
l'aspetto parlando con le persone non
pensando agli egoismi e poi quando
l'intero ecosistema che pian piano
inizia a capire i vantaggi di uno spunto
di innovazione e inizia ad ottana gli
strumenti beh sì allora a questo punto
si capisce di aver contribuito a creare
un possibile nuovo riferimento nello
straordinario percorso del progresso
anche in domini così apparentemente
lontani da all'astrazione del beat e
anzi nel pieno dell'economia rea come
quella dello spostamento di un pacco
forse questa si è un'idea di quella la
pena innamorarsi
[Musica]